ukraine is taking russia to court over
the war it accuses moscow of attacking
on false pretenses by alleging genocide
in two eastern regions of ukraine
russia has not sent a delegation to the
two-day hearing at the international
court of justice kiev wants the u.n body
to order an end to the invasion rulings
issued by the court are binding but
there are no means to actually enforce
its decisions a provisional result is
expected within
days
and our correspondent pablo basil is
following the story for us from brussels
hi barbara can you tell us more about
the opening statement that ukraine has
now delivered in this case
yeah we just heard the leading lawyer
for the ukrainian side give this
statement and he said russia lay down
your arms why do we not settle our
differences like civilized nations do
in front of this court however as you
said the russian side didn't appear but
this was his appeal and he said we
stringently
deny
the allegation of genocide we have
nothing to do with that nothing like
that happened in the eastern part of the
country in
the area of donetsk do show us your
proof and at the same time then of
course he also said that it is the other
side round russia is committing genocide
or is getting ready to do so by
indiscriminately shelling
civilian areas um housing and
and civilian infrastructure and so this
is the basis of this case and it was
outlined uh by the ukrainian side and of
course now a lot of legal arguments are
continuing but it's at the heart of this
russia accuses ukraine ukraine says no
we absolutely did nothing like this but
you you are the real aggressor here and
you are
on the way to commit genocide on the
ukrainian people russia is denying all
of those allegations we should say what
evidence is ukraine presenting in this
case
i mean evidence for that their
allegations are not that hard to find
these days i mean there is endless
footage of journalists endless footage
of civilians footage of course also
by the ukrainian military and government
officials
that show that a lot of civilian areas
and housing blocks and schools and
kindergartens and everything hospitals
even have already been shelled by
russian troops and so that is sort of
giving their argument weight and they
are appealing to the court for a quick
decision because what they want is a
measure is so-called immediate measure
that the court orders russia to stop now
russia will not listen but this is a
legal struggle that we are witnessing
here barbara very quick last question
why is ukraine taking this legal path
very simple to de-legitimize putin and
and his doings and his government and
also to give weight to the sanctions
that are have already been put up
against russia and give way to further
sanctions sort of the give them legal
weight and give them legitimacy that is
really what this is about and in the
future even maybe to get damages
from russia because what we're seeing
there is the destruction of a country
and to rebuild it is going to cost huge
amounts of money now ukraine taking
russia to court over the war our
correspondent papa visilder in brussels
are following the latest on that story
for us thank you very much barbara
let's get around to some other headlines
now japan has called russia's attack on
ukraine's largest nuclear facility an
unforgivable outrageous act russian
soldiers took the zapurichia facility on
friday after shelling it and have
reportedly turned off its internet and
telephone lines the u.n nuclear watchdog
has also voiced its concern reliable
communications are critical to nuclear
plant safety
and several nations are calling on
interpol to suspend russia from the
organization immediately that's
according to the british home secretary
the country cite the threat to public
safety from russia's invasion of ukraine
the law enforcement body is a network of
194 countries
you